>> THIS IS A CHALLENGE OF OUR
COLLECTIVE LIFETIMES.
THE EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO HUMAN
EXISTENCE AS WE KNOW IT AND
EVERY DAY, WE DELAY, THE COST OF
INACTION INCREASES SO LET THIS
BE THE MOMENT THAT WE ANSWER
HISTORIES CALLED.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT BIDEN
OVERSEAS TRYING TO IMPRESS THE
WORLD ON CLIMATE CHANGE, BUT NOT
IMPRESSING ANYBODY HERE AT HOME.
THE PRESIDENT ATTEMPTING TO SAVE
THE PLANET BY WRITING AROUND IN
AN 800 VEHICLES STRONG MOTORCADE
AND BY SENDING A THIRD OF HIS
CABINET AND AN ARMY OF STAFFERS
TO THE GLOBAL WARMING CONFERENCE
IN SCOTLAND.
WHILE THE SITUATION IS SO DIRE,
REACTING BY APPEARING TO TAKE A
NAP DURING THE CLIMATE SPEECH.
MEANWHILE BACK HERE IN AMERICA,
PILING UP AS HIS APPROVAL TANKS.
A WHOPPING 54% AND 71% OF
AMERICANS SAY THEY THINK THE
COUNTRY IS HEADED IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION.
BUT BIDEN SAYS ALL THAT DOESN'T
MATTER TO HIM.
>> THE POLLS WILL GO UP AND
DOWN, WENT BACK UP AND NOW THEY
ARE LOW, LOOK AT EVERY OTHER
PRESIDENT, THE SAME THING HAS
HAPPENED BUT THAT'S NOT WHY I
RAN, I DIDN'T RUN TO DETERMINE
HOW WELL I'M GOING TO DO IN THE
POLLS, I RAN TO MAKE SURE THAT I
FOLLOWED THROUGH WHAT I SAID I
WOULD DO AS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Jesse: SO FELL ASLEEP
DURING THIS CLIMATE THING THAT'S
GOING TO KILL US ALL IN A MATTER
OF YEARS.
>> Sandra: WAKE UP, THIS IS
URGENT AND IF YOU SIT DOWN AND
PUT YOURSELF WATCHING THAT VIDEO
IN ITS ENTIRETY, IT WASN'T 15
SECONDS, IT WAS FULL.
THAT BEING SAID, AS YOU WERE
GOING TO THE OPEN THERE, SO
ELOQUENTLY POINTING OUT THE
SITUATION THAT WE ARE IN AS A
COUNTRY AS THE PRESIDENT SAT
THERE WE HAD TALKED ABOUT IT AT
INFLATION AD NAUSEAM BUT WE ARE
AT A POINT IN THE YEAR WHERE WE
ARE QUICKLY APPROACHING THE
HOLIDAYS AND THE NUMBER ONE
DISCUSSION NOW IS THANKSGIVING
DINNERS CAN CAUSE MORE AND IF
YOU TRY TO FLY TO GRANDMA'S, IT
CAN GET CANCELED BECAUSE OF
VACCINE MANDATES IN BAD WEATHER
ACCORDING TO MANDATES, CHRISTMAS
IS COMING.
THE COMMERCE SECRETARY WHEN
ASKED IF YOU GOING TO GET YOUR
CHRISTMAS PRESENTS ON TIME SAYS
WE ARE DEALING WITH A SUPPLY
CHAIN CRISIS RIGHT NOW, IF YOU
GET IN YOUR CAR, IT WILL COST
YOU TWICE AS MUCH IN SOME AREAS
OF THE COUNTRY.
THERE ARE MAJOR, MAJOR PROBLEMS
AND MAJOR HEADWINDS RIGHT NOW
AND PEOPLE FEEL THAT.
THESE ARE VERY TANGIBLE PROBLEMS
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THAT
DOES NOT PULL WELL FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND THAT REFLECTS
BETTER ON REPUBLICANS PUTTING IN
A PLAN FOR NEXT YEAR.
>> Jesse: GREG FELL ASLEEP
DURING THE COLD OPEN.
YOU UNDERSTAND WHY THE PRESIDENT
MIGHT BE A LITTLE LETHARGIC?
>> Greg: YES.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS BORING AS A
TOPIC THAT'S WHY WE DON'T DO IT
VERY OFTEN NOT THAT THE
STATISTICS AREN'T TRUE, THE
COMPUTER MODELS ARE WAY OFF AND
IT BECOMES A WASTE OF TIME BUT
THIS IS LIKE A FUN HOUSE MIRROR
OF THE PREVIOUS PRESIDENT.
YOU HAD NONSTOP ENERGY THAT WAS
REALLY EXHAUSTING.
TRUMP WAS 24/7 AND BIDEN IS
ZERO.
YOU ALWAYS KNOW HOW THE FAR LEFT
IS DOING AND YOU KNOW THEY ARE
WORKING REALLY WELL IS WHEN
AMERICA'S GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION, THAT IS THE BAROMETER
BECAUSE IF THEY GET THEIR STUFF
RIGHT, MOST OF AMERICANS SHOULD
BE SUFFERING.
IT'S LIKE A MEDIC, WHAT MOMS
GIVE YOU TO THROW UP THE POISON.
THAT'S HOW YOU KNOW IT WORKS IS
WHEN YOU'RE THROWING UP, THAT'S
WHAT IT DOES TO YOU.
BUT IF I WERE JOE BIDEN AND I
HEARD 71% THINKS AMERICA'S GOING
IN THE WRONG DIRECTION, JUDGING
BY THE GOSSIP.
>> Jesse: LET'S JUST SAY HE'S
AT 42% IN THE LATEST HOLE HERE.
THIS IS WHAT THE ENTIRE MEDIA
ESTABLISHMENT DOING ALL THEY CAN
DO PROP THIS GUY UP, IMAGINE IF
HE DIDN'T HAVE ALL THAT, WHEN
HIS NUMBERS WOULD TRULY BE.
>> Katie: WOULD BE PRETTY
ANNOYED THAT PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD
TO PAY THE SAME AMOUNT OF MILK
FOR THEIR KIDS AND THEY CAN'T
EVEN GET BACK TO SCHOOL WITHOUT
ALL THESE RESTRICTIONS BUT GOING
BACK TO THE CEMENT TODAY, IT'S A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF HOW THE LEFT
IS COMPLETELY OUT OF TOUCH WITH
THE SO-CALLED WORKING CLASS THEY
WANT TO REPRESENT.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE ARE AFRAID
OF CLIMATE CHANGE BUT THEY WANT
YOU TO BE REALLY AFRAID OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THEY HAVE PRINCE CHARLES WHO
LIVES IN A PALACE LECTURING
ABOUT HOW HE WANTS A MILITARIZED
CAMPAIGN TO GET THE REST OF
THESE PEOPLE IN LINE.
DOESN'T ALLOW UNDEVELOPED
COUNTRIES TO BECOME DEVELOPED
WHICH IS A HUGE PROBLEM FOR
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD.
THEY WANT TO CONTINUE THEIR
LIVES OF LUXURY, AL GORE SOLD
HIS TV COMPANY POCKETED FUNDED
BY OIL, HE IS THERE, JOHN KERRY
WE TALK ABOUT ALL THE TIME WANTS
TO KEEP JETTING AROUND FOR THE
GOOD OF THE PLANET.
THEY WANT TO BE IN CONTROL AND
CONTROL PEOPLE'S LIVES.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
SOLVING THE ISSUE AND THEN BACK
HOME THEY SAY GAS PRICES WILL GO
UP 40% SO WHILE WE ARE ALL
FLYING INTO SCOTLAND FOR THIS
CONFERENCE, YOUR HOUSE GETS
COLD, JUST THROW ANOTHER SWEAT
AROUND AND DEAL WITH IT LATER.
THAT'S WHY YOU ARE SEEING THESE
NUMBERS IN THE 70s.
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT IS
FALLING ASLEEP AT A CLIMATE
CHANGE CONFERENCE IN EUROPE
WHILE AMERICANS ARE SUFFERING
FROM HIGH GAS PRICES HERE.
IT'S OFF.
>> I FEEL BAD.
YOU GET THAT.
>> Jesse: I DID NOT GET A NAP,
HOW DARE YOU.
I'M A BIG BALLET GUIDE.
>> Harold: I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
THE PRESIDENT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
EXERCISING HIS RIGHT TO PRAYER
OR CONTEMPLATING.
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF THINGS.
CLIMATE CHANGE TO ME IS REALLY
AN EFFORT TO GO AFTER THEIR
BIGGEST GEOPOLITICAL THREAT OF
THE BIGGEST QUESTION WE HAVE IS
A COUNTRY AND THAT'S CHINA.
CHINA IS WE ALL KNOW IF YOU
WEEKS AGO LAUNCHED HYPERSONIC
WEAPON THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME
CAN DELIVER A NUCLEAR WARHEAD
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
THEY LEAD THE WORLD AND ELECTRIC
BATTERY PRODUCTION, SOLAR PANEL
PRODUCTION, WIND TURBINE
PRODUCTION.
ARE THEY RIGHT?
PROBABLY SO.
THEY ARE PREDICTING WHERE THE
WORLD IS GOING TO GO SO I THINK
WE SHOULD BE IN THE BUSINESS OF
COMPETING AND TRYING OUR HARDEST
TO BEAT THEM.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS ALSO AN
ECONOMIC CHALLENGE AROUND THE
GLOBE.
THERE IS SOME HYPOCRISY TO
PEOPLE FLYING IN BIG PLANES,
HAVING ENORMOUS CARBON
FOOTPRINTS AND SOME NOT SAYING
WE SHOULD HAVE IT ALL OF THE
ABOVE ENERGY STRATEGY.
YOU CAN'T OUT OF ONE SIDE SAY
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH WITH IN
TERMS OF SHORTAGES AND PEOPLE
WANTING TO BE WARM DURING THE
WINTER THAT WE SHOULD RELY ON
GRIDS THAT ARE UNRELIABLE.
WE SHOULD INVEST IN EVERYTHING
LOOMING ABOVE ALL STRATEGY THAT
ALL WEALTHY AND THE
UPPER-MIDDLE-CLASS PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO LIVE BY.
WE ARE NOT DOING THAT AND I
THINK DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
ALIKE HAVE SOME BLAME BUT FOR
ME, IT'S CHINA.
>> Jesse: I JUST WANTED TO
HEAR THAT.
>> Harold: THEY HAVE OVER A
BILLION PEOPLE THEY ARE TRYING
TO MANAGE IN THEIR BELIEF IS
OVER THE NEXT TEN TO 20 YEARS,
THE RICHEST MAN IN THE WORLD IS
DEVELOPING ELECTRIC BATTERIES
AND ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
SENDING PEOPLE TO SPACE AND WAS
FAR OFF AS YOU MAY THINK I AM,
THE GUY RIGHT BEHIND HIM BUT
ALSO A IN CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> Jesse: ANYTHIN